in the 1990s Jim Carrey became one of
the biggest stars in the world thanks to
hit films like Ace Ventura pet detective
Dumb and Dumber the mask and liar liar'
he's an incredibly likable actor and
also a very loose performer he
improvises a lot so when you combine
that with his manic energy it results in
lots of unexpected moments of him
cracking up his co-stars and himself
here are some behind the scenes clips
from Jim Carrey movies outtakes so good
that they could have been in the movies
themselves Almighty then Bruce Almighty
is a high concept blockbuster where
Carrey stars as a TV reporter who gets
to take a crack at being God in this
blooper an agitated Bruce has to cut off
a conversation because he's running late
for work
generally actors who have to drive in
movies don't actually drive instead the
car is placed on a rig so that the crew
can control exactly where it goes
this outtake reveals that secret as
Carrie fiddles with the controls and
pretends to zoom out of the neighborhood
pappan with the Penguins mr. Popper's
Penguins stars carry as a guy who opens
up his apartment to dozens of the tuxedo
colored polar birds for many of the
shots the production used real penguins
and they've got genuine comedic chops in
this outtake Carrey attempts to
establish comic rapport with a prickly
penguin who reluctantly obliges first
the bird completely ignores his attempts
at friendliness then when he attempts
the old it's for you bit with a phone
the little critter amusingly snaps its
beak as a clever retort I'll introduce
you somebody was to talk water in the
court in Liar Liar Carrey plays a sleazy
lawyer who is physically unable to say
anything but the truth
ironically enough in this outtake the
joke is based on a lie after an exchange
with co-star Jennifer Tilly Carrey pours
himself a glass of water from a pitcher
he knows that neither the glass nor the
pitcher is going to appear on screen but
that the sound will register so it's the
perfect opportunity for Kerry to make it
seem like he's relieving himself in the
courtroom
[Music]
something about Merry Christmas in this
moment from dumb and dumber to best
friends Harry Dunne and Lloyd Christmas
are having one of their little arguments
in the outtake Carrie adds some highly
theatrical laughing his co-star jeff
daniels doesn't break character instead
managing to improvise this line about
merit it's a joke that works on two
levels referencing both the name of
Lloyd's unattainable dream woman from
the original Dumb and Dumber
as well as another very successful
Farrelly Brothers film hello Clarice
Carrie departed from his wheelhouse of
likable idiots in the 1996 dark comedy
the Cable Guy he plays a TV installer
who befriends a regular guy and then
stalks him and tries to ruin his life
one of the movies most famous scenes
takes place at medieval times Carrie
puts a bunch of meat on his face and
references Hannibal Lecter from The
Silence of the Lambs it was apparently
so funny to Carrie in Matthew Broderick
that they struggled to film the scene
without cracking up
the best that's incredibly disgusting
very hard agreed on my face yes fun with
Jim and props Jim Carrey knows a thing
or two about physical comedy but that
doesn't necessarily mean he's the most
physically coordinated actor in this
outtake from fun with Dick and Jane
Carrie suburban dad turned criminal is
supposed to celebrate a successful phone
call by throwing the phone from one hand
to the other but he can't quite seem to
pull it off as he drops the phone and
sends it flying when he actually does
manage to catch it he pauses to savor
the moment but for so long that the take
is unusable a series of fortunate riffs
a series of unfortunate events is based
on Lemony Snicket's gothic children's
novel about the orphan Baudelaire
children with Carrie as villainous
master of disguise Count Olaf there
ended up being plenty of extra footage
in this clip he improvises a song about
a time machine that leads him to
imitating a clock gone mad which then
leads to his top-notch dinosaur
impression somehow his co-stars continue
to pretend to sleep even as he runs
around him well does this
what's my name again anchorman - did
everything the first anchorman did only
much bigger and set in the 80s instead
of the 70s
this included revisiting the first
film's epic news anchor battle royale
the original fight featured only local
San Diego news teams while the second
increased the stakes with national and
international squads there were cameos
galore including Carrie and Marion
Cotillard as a Canadian duo though
Carrie is a native Canuck his characters
exaggerated accent made it hard for him
to spit out his lines
what the hell's my name Scott Brock got
Riley there's not gonna be a fight
without Ron what's my name
my name is not Ron